Zulu King goodwills where Latini has
condemned these nfo Berkut acts on my
immigrants rather in South Africa as
vile it was called on his tribal
subjects to stop the violence
he's also denied that he sparked the
attacks by comments he made about
foreigners earlier this month we spoke
to the journalists of Romani in Kesey in
Johannesburg I think good was really
teeny made us a speech in Poland
northern kaizad in we called for foreign
nationals to to pack their bags and go
he's since said that he said his words
were misinterpreted but particularly by
members of the media and he didn't
intend for for the xenophobic violence
to to actually erupt in in the province
people have been complaining and saying
there hasn't been responsible leadership
particularly from him because he's got
so much influence amongst two DP 'pl and
amongst people of kwazulu-natal they
felt that his words were very
irresponsible for a person who has that
much influence now we saw the king :
embezzle which is a silly word for a
gathering and in that's a meeting he he
called upon his subjects to lay down
their arms and he renounced the violence
that had been going on that message was
very important for him to make because
at the King in some regards in
particularly in question itself is seen
as being above politicians you know so
whatever he says his subjects will
actually will take heed of that we've
also seen incidences of xenophobia
violence happen in shouting particularly
in Alexandra and Alexandra has got a
very large community of of serious
speakers so we're still waiting to see
if King Goodwill's really teenies
message of peace will actually resonate
with in kwazulu-natal and within some of
the townships in pouting in the stands I
heard many of [ __ ] good walls really
teenies subjects say that they wanted to
go to my point area in the Durban CBD
for an attack on the foreign nationals
over there so King goodwill really teeny
speech was very important to calm
tensions among these subjects and to
calm tensions in the province because
the King is a very powerful man if he
makes a decree and he says that his
subjects should act in a particular way
many people do listen instead of
listening to the politicians so he's a
very powerful man and so the politicians
actually roped him in and asked him
to call upon the symbiote and and to
three subjects in order to calm the
violence and the attention that had been
going on in kwazulu-natal for the past
three weeks it remains to be seen if his
words will be heeded but from what I
could see his words were well received
many of the people at the stadium before
the king made his speech they were
pulling upon going on the attack but
after his speech they lost that that
will to fight they accepted what the
King said and decided to go home
peacefully even though many of them are
still unhappy a lot of people were
mentioning very derogatory words against
foreign nationals saying that they will
still catch them though so you know the
they will they'll still beat them up if
they see them on the street so on and so
on but in terms of a collective sense of
violence amongst the people there that
did dissipate after this the the King
made his speech so in the coming days or
so we will see if the Kings efforts were
successful in in quelling the violence
in the in the province